Remedy Entertainment the studio behind
Max Payne and quantum break has filed a
trademark for alan wake's return
sparking speculation that everybody's
favorite flashlight wielding author may
be back I'm Lucy and welcome to this
Stephen King inspired gamespot news
update the trademark listing was spotted
on the European Union trademark database
by neogaf user ekam who also noted that
an alan wake's return website was
registered in 2015 although the listing
states Remedy Entertainment is the owner
of the trademark submission it is
possible that the studio wasn't involved
and it was instead submitted by a third
party also worth remembering that a
trademark registration doesn't
necessarily mean that a new project is
in development but in September 2014
remedies creative director Sam Lake said
the studio would like to return to Alan
Wake someday he said we're really really
proud of all the games we have made and
obviously all of them are dear to us
they have a special place in our hearts
you never know about the future and as
we have said about Alan Wake the sequel
didn't work out at this point but
definitely we are looking for
opportunities to do more someday when
the time is right in February 2016 Lake
also said that although remedy explored
designs for an Alan Wake sequel after
the first game was released fees were
then abandoned since then remedy has
come up with much better ideas for Alan
Wake too you've been iterating the idea
of what an Alan Wake sequel could be and
along the way there has been much better
ideas than what the concept coming out
of Alan Wake was for the sequel among
other things we are discussing the
possibility of an alan wake's equal with
multiple partners but nothing has been
decided would you play an Alan Wake
sequel let me know in the comments below
I'll come find me on Twitter I Malusi
James games for all the latest on Alan
Wake keep it gamespot
you